as the russian siege on the ukrainian
city of mariopol continues intent on
crushing any remaining resistance the
white house says it's sending new
shipments of military aid to help
ukrainians fight back we're in a
critical window now
and the united states and our allies and
partners are moving as fast as possible
to continue to provide ukraine the
forces that they need the weapons they
need excuse me the equipment they need
their forces need to defend their nation
the latest aid package announced the
same day the ukrainian prime minister
was in washington meeting with u.s
president joe biden and military leaders
it totals 800 million in heavy artillery
including 72 howitzers
144 000 rounds of ammunition and follows
more than a billion in security
assistance already sent to ukraine
however
with this latest disbursement
i've almost exhausted the drawdown
authority i have the congress authorized
for ukraine that's why next week biden
will ask congress for even more money to
continue the flow of weapons but as for
where these weapons go once handed out
the white house admits there's little
accountability
the failure to track who is receiving
u.s weapons alarms members of the
president's own democratic party
congresswoman ilhan omar last month
tweeted the consequences could be
disastrous if weapons are given to
paramilitary groups such as the
far-right linked as off battalion
without accountability a lot of these
weapons also end up in conflicts outside
of the country and this is the the one
of the primary concerns it's really out
of the control of the united states
you know when we provide weapons we try
to ask the countries to agree to use
them and control them in certain ways
but ultimately that's not something we
can
have control over
for decades the u.s government has armed
non-state groups in iraq afghanistan
libya syria and elsewhere
often with unintended consequences most
recently in afghanistan weapons supplied
by the united states to fight the
taliban are now being used by some
militias against civilians to commit
human rights violations
the defense department is calculating
just how much money the white house will
need from congress for weapons for
ukraine whatever the amount president
biden says the goal is to keep the
weapons flowing without interruption
kimberly helkin al jazeera the white
house